hey guys
welcome to jenkins pipeline tutorial by
simply learn
my name is chidanan and let me quickly
walk you through the topics that i plan
to cover
as a part of this tutorial at a very
high level i'll be introducing you
jenkins
and then get into more details of the
continuous integration process
as most of you are aware most of the
software's in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices
and continuous integration is an
important or
key factor in all such agile software
development
life cycle next i'll be looking at the
software delivery pipeline
from a perspective of if someone were to
visualize
all the steps that is required from the
time someone gives out a requirement
a software requirement it gets
translated into some sort of a code and
gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then
migrated across or moved across or
propagated across various
environments and then finally put out in
production if
one were to put a value stream mapping
for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within jenkins
i will first look at what existed in
jenkins
or rather pre-jenkins 2.0 where we had a
way of upstream downstream mapping of
jobs
there were some plugins that allowed us
to visualize all the jobs
at one shot starting from the first job
that triggered and then
i will get into the most powerful groovy
scripting
that are there in jenkins 2.0 outpost
jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful
ways of defining our pipelines there are
two different
ways in which you can write your scripts
one is the scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change
or difference between each one of them
but these gives you
a much more flexible and much more
powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery
having said that most of these topics
that i'm going to discuss will be
followed up with
a demo and the source code for most of
these would be
on our github repository so what exactly
is jenkins
jenkins is nothing but a powerful
automation server
that is written in java and it is a web
application
which can also be run on any web server
but what makes jenkins an ideal choice
for a continuous integration server
jenkins has got wonderful plugins that
allows
it to connect to all kinds of tools
software development
deployment coding build source code kind
of tools
that is what makes jenkins very very
powerful
from a continuous integration
perspective jenkins can connect to
various source code servers and it has
also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test
all kinds of software artifacts so this
is what makes
jenkins an ideal choice for a continuous
integration server
but mind you for me jenkins is nothing
but a very very powerful
automated server at the heart of it
there's a lot of automation in it
but the powerfulness of jenkins is more
so because of
the tools that it integrates with and
the kind of plugins that it has got
what is continuous integration from a
software development
life cycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
sprints
maybe three to four weeks is your
delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations
who are working on the same code base on
the same branch
if the code check-ins do not happen
quickly as in
every day if at all developers stagger
their code check-ins into the repository
finding problems at a later stage would
be very costly for the whole project
early detection of any such issues would
be you know quick to resolve and
would not affect your delivery schedules
so as a part of continuous integration
what is requested or what is demanded is
that every developer checks in code
pretty much you know every day as long
as it doesn't break the code
he checks in code pretty much regularly
and at the end of
a day you have an automated server which
kind of wakes up
pulls the latest code so this code has
got the integrations of all the code
bases
that has been checked in by various
developers so it pulls out the code
it builds on a completely different
server
that is the ci server which pulls this
code it builds it it's got
all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it
and assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test suites
automated if you're at all there is a
way by which in a couple of hours time
when the team is out
or rather team sleeping you have
verification that happens
at a very crucial level and then any
breakages even before the team arrives
for the next day
if these are notified to the whole team
members saying an email going out
saying that something got broken most of
the code would be pretty
okay from the perspective of compilation
errors or build errors
it is the functionality and the
regression that the team is worried
about so if these can be automated
test it very very quickly and very very
fast and then
any breakages are detected early during
the day right by the time the next day
people come in
they know what is broken and possibly
they know what code
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick
stand-up meeting and then they discuss
what broke the code and able to fix it
so this way any problem that could
possibly arise
at a later point in time if at all they
kind of move to the
initial phase of the project any
detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and jenkins plays
an important role in being the
continuous integration server because
it's got connections to anything and
everything all kinds of tools i mean and
then
it is also got various ways on which
triggering the job which is a part of
its automation strategy
now that we know what is continuous
integration and where does
jenkins come into picture let's look at
the rest of the tasks of our software
development lifecycle
so if at all i were to visualize the
kind of steps that is involved
in delivering my software possibly the
continuous integration phase would be
somewhere here
where multiple developers are developing
on that and then we have a little bit of
a stable code that is there that can be
kind of moved across because
i want to go ahead with the particular
build that i have
and then i want to migrate that i want
to propagate that
across various environments so if you
consider the
standard software delivery approach in
the first cycle you just do some minimal
testing
and then you kind of move that to one of
the environments and from there you kick
off more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance test they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test there could be a load test
it could be a system
integration test all kinds of tests that
you can think about
and all the way may be propagating the
build across various environments
if all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves across various
phases
if there's any failure of course the
build propagation kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well
so your workflow is progressing well and
at the end of the workflow
you eventually have a code which is
pretty much
good to release now mind you i make an
assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage
of your test cases but if that is not
the scenario then possibly there are
some
automated tests or checks that may be
required in between
but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well
you know you can visualize this as the
steps that is required for your software
development
or software delivery life cycle now in
jenkins the way this kind of translates
is that
each of these tasks can be put out as a
job so now let me quickly
let you know or let me quickly demo what
existed in pre-genkins 2.0
where i could put up a couple of jobs
and i can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism
so if this job one if at all it is a
build and even test cases
if at all that passes successfully job 2
gets triggered
if the job 2 is more about running some
more automated tests
or possibly deploying it to environment
and then kicking off some more test
cases
that would be job 2 but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail
it would not propagate to the third job
all right so let me
quickly bring up my jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that
or rather how could one connect that
using
jenkins 2.0 or pre jenkins 2.0 release
i have now brought up my jenkins
instance and in case
some of you don't know how to install
jenkins or you don't know how to bring
up your jenkins instance
i would strongly recommend that you
watch our previous videos on
simply learn youtube channel where i've
detailed out the steps that is required
for you to
install jenkins and bring it up so all
right so i've brought up my jenkins
instance let me put up few of those
jobs now mind you i'm going to cover the
pre
jenkins 2.0 feature here all right so
let me put up my first job
all right i hope i don't have that job i
say it's a freestyle project
i don't want to change anything i'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here it's in batch command let's say
echo
first job triggered
at right that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job i've got a
very very simple
echo statement in this so it just prints
out the system date and the time in it
all right so i could run these jobs
individually if i want so
let me just check running my third job
so this is what i get
in the console output third job
triggered at date and time oops
let me fix that
right that should fix it let me check my
second job
all right that's my second job all right
so
i've got three jobs now if i were to
link them together
or if at all i want a scenario where
after the first job is successfully run
i would like to trigger my second job so
i would do a small configuration change
in here
i would say after this first job is run
i want to trigger the second job
so i have something called as a post
build action
so i can say that trigger some other
jobs from here
so if you see this publish record deploy
all right trigger trigger trigger
trigger let me check the other one
build other projects this is what i
would want to do so after the first job
is done i want to trigger my second job
all right i would say save this now let
me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done right i'll add this
post build
build other projects third job again
i'm not really sure if you guys notice
this there is various configurations as
to when exactly do you want to
trigger the other job and the default
one is trigger only if the build is
stable
so typically this is the configuration
that would need we definitely don't want
the third job to be triggered
in case the second job fails all right
so this is the combination that i want
or this is the choice that i want
and i save this now i have three of my
jobs
if you see this the second job the
upstream job
is the first job so let me check this
kind of a pipeline what i've set here is
a very very simple pipeline so after my
first job gets triggered
if i build this guy right the second job
gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
i click on the second job
all right so the first job was to get
the second job and after the second job
it is triggering the third job
so this is how first job second job and
third job were kind of linked but it's
pretty
hard to visualize this as to you know if
i need to see one holistic picture
where after the first job after the
second job after the third job what was
the flow
it's not possible for me to visualize
that that's where in i install a plugin
so let me go to manage plugins right
here i think i already have it installed
for those of you don't have it installed
you can go to the available
button i mean available tab and click on
that the plugin is called delivery
pipeline plugin i already have it
installed in case you don't have it
installed you just go to the available
you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plugin that
i want you to install
all right so now we have that plugin
installed so what i want to do is after
the plugin is installed you see
something like this
so this is where i would create a new
visualization for the pipeline that i've
created
so i would say my first pipeline or i
give a name for my visualization
i would say yes this upstream downstream
dependencies this is exactly what i want
and there are a bunch of settings here
i'll not look at any of that now what i
want is
i just want to tell this view that you
know the i can give a name for this
i would give it as simply learn pipeline
and what's important is that
i specify what is the first job that
should be picked up as a part of this
pipeline and the final job is optional
because it knows that if the first job
is triggering those other jobs
it knows where to end this whole uh life
cycle so i
define a pipeline and they give a name
for my component and initialize that as
my i mean i give it the first job so i
say okay
and there you go this is much better
this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if i click on any of these
that will in fact take me to the job all
right there is also one other option
which is
pretty good option in my opinion which
is about
edit view yes this is where it is enable
start of a new pipeline build
let me apply and let me click ok on this
what it gives me is a way
in which i can trigger my whole pipeline
from here so if i click on this
there you see the first job getting
trigger the second job is still running
the green means it's all run properly
and nicely second one is triggered now
the third one is
still running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see
there's a one-to-one mapping but if at
all you remember
we could go and add multiple
dependencies for the projects that i set
in just to give an example
let's say if i go to my first job i can
do a configuration here
and nothing stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me a
comma
i can trigger multiple jobs here in case
if i have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the
most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run
prior to jenkins 2.0 now this feature
became such an
important feature the users wanted more
and more complicated because the
pipelines were
a lot complicated it was not just one
job after the other there were multiple
jobs that has to be run
and there is also an introduction of the
jenkins agents
where multiple tasks could be parallelly
run on different agents so they wanted
to club
all of that and the pipeline could have
all the such complicated stuff
that's where in post jenkins 2.0 or in
jenkins 2.0
jenkins released a version which has got
the feature of pipeline which can be
written in groovy scripts now groovy
is wonderful scripting language it's
very very powerful
anybody can visualize your pipeline or
write your pipeline
using programming language and the point
of
everything is code where this whole
groovy script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here
and in case my jenkins kind of fails you
know there's a crash on my jenkins i
don't get back these jobs
how do i bring back all these jobs back
so
everything is good that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts
that is what i'm going to do in my next
exercise in my previous example
i showed you the crude way in my opinion
of putting up a jenkins pipeline but
this is what existed prior to jenkins
2.0
and now i have post jenkins 2.0 in terms
of my version jenkins version
is 2.107. so this supports something
called as a scripted pipeline
wherein you can write your pipeline in
terms of groovy scripts no need to put
up any jobs here and remember how
exactly you put up these individual jobs
you can write a pipeline script
in terms of groovy language let me
quickly show you a very very
simple and elementary pipeline that i
have this is what a groovy script would
look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined
as a subset of these stages so the first
stage is the compile stage
and stage has got some steps in it you
can have multiple steps in it and
once only after all these steps
successfully complete
that's when the stage gets through
perfectly with the pass
so there's a compile a stage there's a j
unit stage
there's a quality gate stage there's a
deploy stage and i'm really not doing
anything much within this other than
echoing you know some text within each
of these stages
and what's interesting is at the end
there's something called as a post
which is similar to or you can kind of
equate that to what would be there in a
try catch kind of a block
supposed always meaning this would run
all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures
so typically you would have your email
that is going out here saying that the
build is successful and stuff like that
failure if something went bad if any of
the step
resulted in a failure this particular
block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
failed within your test run and you
would want to
mark the build as unstable are changed
this is an interesting option
so this compares the present run with
the previous run and if there's any
change
meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa this would get triggered
so this is what a simple pipeline
script would look like so let me copy
this pipeline and let me put up a simple
job for running this pipeline so let me
open up my jenkins
say a new i would say scripted pipeline
yeah this is what i want
i don't want to choose a freestyle
project this is going to be a pipeline
project
so i would say pipeline and say okay all
right this has got
far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so
general i don't want anything here i
don't want any build trigger
right so this is where i kind of i can
paste in whatever i had copied there's
also something called as a pipeline
syntax or a
syntax generator this is like a lookup
where you can choose what you want to do
and choose the option that is specific
to those steps and you will get a
pipeline
generator or a script generated for you
jenkins knows that you're not very good
at understanding these pipelines
so this gives you the sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline
and then get the equivalent groovy
script from here let me
look at this in a bit later so for now i
have my pipeline syntax already copied
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
paste
what i copied all right so this looks
good okay i'm not connecting to any
github repository of any of that
i'm just running a very very simple
pipeline which has got some steps in it
and it just compiles or rather it just
puts out some messages saying that this
stage completed successfully and stuff
like that so let me save this
and let me try to run this scripted
pipeline all right if you see this
you'll see each of those steps going
through and if at all i look at the
console output
compiled successfully unit passed all
the stages passed there was a pass
the failures doesn't show up you will
see the messages
from our post or the try catch block
that i was mentioning earlier
so this is how one would put up a
pipeline and you also get to see the
visualized view
of your pipeline that says which stage
run after which phase how much time did
it take and you can click
on any of these and get into looking at
the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me
give you another scenario for a pipeline
wherein
the source code of my pipeline would be
in a github repository
and i will write scripts to grab this
particular code
and run some part of the code which is
there as a part of the repository
so let me look at the repository that i
have i have a repository out here
on the simply learn github account which
is called the pipeline script
and if you see in there there are a
bunch of batch files that are there
so the first batch file would be a
build.batch so there's nothing in it
except that
it is just trying to build a particular
project you can visualize this
as individual batch files which actually
contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your
particular project so i have a couple of
batch files that is here
and this is on the github repository so
i would need to write
jenkins job which will log into my
github account
and then check out this particular
repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps
within within the scripted pipeline so
let me
check as to how i could do that
let me put up a new project for this
let me call this scripted pipeline
scripted pipeline from
github all right so let this be a
pipeline project
that's good enough for me let me see my
scripts
all right now this is where i need to
put in the scripts for
pulling out the code repository from my
github server
and running those batch files that are
there as a part of the repository so
what i want to do is i already have
the skeleton of my pipeline that is
written which is very similar to
whatever was the pipeline syntax that i
showed you in the previous step
so i just copy this out here and then
paste it here so what i have here is
i've written on the
high level skeleton without really
putting in the actual steps required for
checking out rather or rather running
those build scripts
so i've got four steps one is the git
checkout step the builds tab
unit test quality gate and possibly the
deploy
all right so i need to put in the actual
scripts that is required for first
checking out the repository from my
github server so this is where i will
make use of this
pipeline syntax so as i mentioned
earlier
you have a bunch of help that is
available for you to figure out the
actual scripts that is required for you
to write within your pipeline so what i
wanted to do is
check out something from git so it's get
related so search on git
and you'll find this option so i got to
specify my git
repository url and my credentials so
let me look at the repository url this
would be my repository url so let me
copy this
i'm going to copy the https url of my
repository
and branch is good and one thing that
you got to notice is for now the
repository is anyway a public repository
on github so even though if you don't
specify
any credentials that would work for me
still but in case you have a repository
which
needs strictly a username and password
to be specified you can kind of add it
out
here using add jenkins and you can give
your username and password out here but
for now i don't need
any of these things so i'm going to just
say get checkout
or rather the url of my repository and
what we want
is the master branch for now i have only
one branch on my github server so this
is good for me so this is what
exactly i want to do as a part of the
script so if i click this
this is the script that i need to put in
my build script
so i come over here and this is what
will check out the code from my
repository all right so now
once i get my code onto my repository
from my repository rather
it will grab those code all these patch
files and get it onto my jenkins
workspace
now i'll have to run these batch files
as a part of each of my step
so let me look at what would be the
syntax so the first one that i want to
run would be my build.bat all right
so i want to run a batch file all right
and what is the name of the batch file
that i want to
run i want to run this build.bat so
generate pipeline script
this is all that i got to specify as a
part of my
build step and then unit test i'm gonna
just
change this to unit i think that's what
i have
in my repository okay that is unit and
then
deploy and quality queue capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository
and check out my source code and grab it
and take it to the
jenkins workspace so from this workspace
since
all the files are there in the root
directory of this workspace
it will run these batch files one after
the other all right
let me save this and let me try to run
my pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to
get the source code from my repository
whoa whoa whoa that was fast
all right so it pulled out all the
source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was
pulled out it was this create deploy dot
bad
that looks good i'm saying building
checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what i've had in my
build.bat if i'm not mistaken okay
building the project that's what is
there with the timestamp
running unit test cases unit.bat it is
running unit.bat
and then giving me the date and
timestamp okay so all these kind of
passed
and if i go back to the project i will
also see this beautiful
view of how exactly what is the time
that was taken for checking out the
repository
running the build on bat running the
unit test cases quality gates and all
this
isn't that pretty simple now let me
modify my previous job or rather let me
put up a new job
for making use of an agent wherein i
could delegate
a job to an engine typically agents
can be brought up on any other remote
machines other than where your primary
gen can server is running
in case you don't know or you don't know
how to start up these agents
i would strongly recommend that you
refer to our previous uh
jenkins video on the simply learn
youtube channel
alright so let me just check the status
of my agent for now yes he's offline
so let me start this agent because agent
is not running
so i have the agent set up in my sql on
agents
so let me copy the script file that is
required for starting my agent
let me go to the agents folder open up a
command prompt
and let me try to bring up my agent all
right so the agent is up and running
for now i don't have the luxury of
starting my agent on a different machine
so my agent is running on my same
machine
but the agent's workspace is sql agent
while my primary jenkins server is
running
has the workspace out here colon program
files
86 and this is the workspace of my
jenkins all right i hope you can kind of
differentiate
those two all right so now what i want
is i look at the same
job that i put in earlier or rather
modify that let the steps be the same
but i don't want to run that on my
master
server let me try to delegate that using
the script
so let me put up an agent
scripted job all right it will be
a pipeline rep job see okay
and let me copy this was a step that i
had put in
for my previous job so agent any
so what i'm gonna do now is i don't want
this to be running on any other agent
i want this to be running on the agent
whose
label is let me check what is the label
of my agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
windows note
so let me just copy that there all right
so
with a very subtle change instead of
saying agent any
i'm going to run or rather i'm going to
specify the agent who will be running
this job
is the one who has got the label as
windows note so this agent that i
brought on my
system has got the name as windows node
and it is configured to pick up
any job that matches the label to which
any job is kind of delegated
so let me come back to my jobs where is
my
scripted agent job
i've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that i
left halfway through
so here in the pipeline what i'm going
to do is
this is all i'm going to need so the job
remains the same
kit checkout is going to check out from
the same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change
is just to ensure that this job is kind
of delegated on the
agent all right so this would be my
agent job
let me save this and let me get back to
the dashboard and let me run it from
here if you see this you know the master
and agent
are both idle as of now let me try to
run this agent scripted job
all right so the agent kind of kicked in
and there's a job that was delegated to
the agent
if i look at what is there in the
console output he's pretty much doing
whatever was there as a part of the job
but the interesting thing to notice that
this is the new workspace
or rather this is delegated to the agent
and the agent's workspace is this
particular folder so this is where it's
going to get all this stuff
run the whole thing and you know the
flow is pretty much the same the only
thing is
this whole thing ran on the agent if i
need to check my agent
i would see the workspace out here agent
scripted job if you look at this
all the batch files are here and this is
where the job was kind of delegated to
run so with a very subtle change
in index scripting i can ensure that the
jobs are kind of delegated onto the
agent the pipeline job specifically
as i mentioned earlier jenkins provides
you two different ways of
writing pipelines called the scripted
and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline this is
heavily based on groovy scripting since
jenkins
ships along with the groovy engine so
this was the first
script or the first support for pipeline
that was provided by jenkins in
2.0 this needs a little bit of a
learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts
based on groovy at a very high level
this is what a typical scripted pipeline
would look like
something called as a node node
represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running
and then a bunch of stages are put out
with each of the stage
along with the steps that needs to be
covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other so all these
stages if they're run peacefully
then the whole task is kind of marked as
run successfully since understanding
groovy or learning groovy was a little
tough for many of the people
so this is a new one from jenkins
wherein it provides you a much
simple and friendly syntax for writing
pipelines
without really needing to understand or
without nearly reading to
learn some groovy scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of
lookups for figuring out what is a
better pipeline for you to kind of write
but if you can figure out the difference
or if you can try to
find that particular piece of code which
kind of helps you out with your pipeline
either of the skips there's not really
any difference in writing or kind of
delivering your pipeline using either of
these
two methods all right so a pipeline is
something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any
it will pick up whatever is an available
agent and run the job
and then you have something called a
stages stages is nothing but a
collection of
stage and stage could have multiple
steps defined within this
so if any of the steps in any of the
stage fails then that particular
complete stage and the build is marked
as failure so
very subtle difference between both
these two
syntax but using either of these you can
write powerful
scripts for your pipeline now let me
come up with an example
where i'm going to at least demo one of
the feature
where you could run a master and a slave
job
in parallel so let me come up with a
demo for that particular
scenario let me put up a new job for my
parallel agent pipeline let me call this
and this would be a pipeline project
i don't want anything here let me look
at the pipeline script that i have
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage
where this would be a kind of
non-parallel stage where there's a need
for you to
possibly pull out the source code from
one of the repositories
and possibly unit tested if all the unit
test cases pass
then possibly you want to deploy it to
one of the test environments
that would be what would be there as a
part of the non-parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run
and assuming that you know you have a
windows node you have a linux node you
have some other kind of an operating
system based node
you could run these stages in parallel
so for
just for demonstration i've just put in
two parallel stages
in parallel is the keyword that you're
going to use for running tests parallely
so i would say parallel stage test on
windows
and i'm going to run this in my windows
note well i could run a bunch of steps
that i want out here
and then in the other stage or other
step what i want is
i will run something else on on my
master as long as this parallel
keyword is encountered jenkins will
ensure that these two stages are run
parallely
for now i have both these things running
on my same machine but assuming that
these were running on different boxes
you could kind of visualize it as
these two steps are going to be started
parallely without really any dependency
on each other
and then you could wait for the test
results and then based upon whether both
of these steps passed or failed if one
of them failed then we could kind of
mark the build
accordingly so let me copy this pretty
pretty simple
script let me put this out here and now
let me save this out
and let me try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is the non-parallel
stage that's going to happen
then the task one on agent task one one
master followed by
as i said since i have only one node or
rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you not really
see a benefit of this but assuming that
you have couple of boxes on which you
have multiple agents running
you possibly want to run your selenium
tests on the windows box because
selenium brings up some of those
ui which needs a browser you could
possibly need some
regression test that could run on linux
boxes or linux agents
and then you can kind of break down your
tasks
into multiple things that is running on
multiple systems at the same time
and then collate all the results okay
one final thing all right now i have
all my particular job or rather the
steps required for my
pipeline put down in terms of the
scripts and
this is saved in this particular job
that's not a good
recommended approach so what i'll do is
i'll copy all of these steps out here
and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say
let me go back to this repository the
most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a jenkins file
jenkins file and you paste all the
scripts that is required for your
pipeline
now this is in a true sense the devops
approach where
i'm going to save this out so if at all
you have a pipeline defined for your
project
the best place to kind of put out your
configurations for the pipeline is
within your repository
so this may be a different project that
i was referring to but assuming that you
have your project
where you know you have to define your
pipeline instead of putting that as a
particular
job on jenkins and fearing that if
jenkins fails other jobs
if there's a crash and then you lose out
your job configuration
the best approach is to use a jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull
the source code from here as well as use
the steps that is defined in the jetkins
file
so let me end up by putting up another
job which is a true jobs kind of a job
so i would say devops
pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then i'm not going to say any of
these things i would say
the pipeline script is from the source
code management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in scm so
what is my svn i mean what is my
source code repository this is my source
code repository where i already have
this so
let me copy this url this is my url
i don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required
i would say and the scripted file it
automatically picks up jenkins file
all right so let me save this let me
build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein i
have a pipeline that is defined
and instead of putting the pipeline as a
job because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration
the configuration is also checked into
the source code repository and any
changes to this pipeline instead of
putting that
modifications in the job these are all
captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change that concludes
our tutorial
on jenkins pipelines and i hope you
enjoyed watching this video
for more such learnings keep watching
our simply learn youtube
channel thank you so much and have a
great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here